wer die afg wählt ist wahrscheinlich ein
alter mann aus dem osten und afd wähler
haben nur flüchtlingspolitik in kopf und
sind alle protestwähler solche klischees
habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon mal so
oder so ähnlich gehört aber kann man
menschen so über einen kamm scheren
junge leute sind ja auch nicht
ausnahmslos links und viren sich fürs
klima und trinken latte macchiato mit
hafer milch oder aber auch schon mal ein
video zu gemacht das findet ihr oben auf
dem bbi verlinkt was ist da dran an den
afd klischees denn immer wieder gibt es
viele diskussionen auch im internet also
sprechen wir heute mal über die
alternative für deutschland wie ist die
aktuelle situation wer wählt sie
wirklich und wird die afg sich als feste
größe in der parteienlandschaft auf
dauer etablieren
[Musik]
übrigens sagt uns schon mal in den
kommentaren eure meinung was haltet ihr
von der afd unten gerne in die
kommentare posten bei der bundestagswahl
2021 hat die afg mit 10,3 prozent
abgeschnitten das ist nicht wenig aber
im vergleich zum großen erfolg 2017 hat
die afg 2,3 prozentpunkte verloren von
der drittstärksten wurde sie zur fünf
stärksten fraktionen der jubel ist also
etwas verhalten gewesen allerdings ist
auch klar geworden im osten schnitt die
afd deutlich besser ab als im westen die
partei konnte in bundesländern wie
sachsen oder thüringen sehr gute
ergebnisse erzielen und hat wenig oder
gar keine stimmen verloren im westen ist
es anders auch dass er dazu beigetragen
interne machtkämpfe um den künftigen
kurs zu verschärfen und hat dabei den
radikaleren stimmen auftrieb gegeben
schon seit jahren ist bei der afg klar
es gibt verschiedene strömungen eine
scheinbar gemäßigtere seite rund um jörg
neun oder bis zur bundestagswahl 2017
auch noch frauke petry und eine
extremere strömung die vor allem im
osten erfolgreich ist rundum jörn röcke
und den formal aufgelösten flügel der
vom verfassungsschutz als erwiesen
rechtsextremistische bestrebungen
eingestuft wurde bei einer wahlkampfrede
in sachsen anhalt soll heute den spruch
alles für deutschland benutzt haben am
ende dieser rede das ist eine
formulierung die auch die
paramilitärische sogenannte
sturmabteilung der nsdap verwendet hat
die esa und schon 2017 hatte boecker das
holocaust mahnmal in berlin als denkmal
der schande bezeichnet der machtkampf
und damit der kampf um die inhaltliche
ausrichtung spitzt sich bei der afg
immer weiter zu die internen
auseinandersetzungen werden auch
öffentlich sichtbar zum beispiel bei der
bewertung der wahlergebnisse wir mögen
ja wirklich in die differenz haben wenn
wir in der beurteilung ich muss ganz
klar sagen dass ich das ergebnis - und
uns auch nicht schlecht reden lassen
lasse jungen leuten hat inzwischen
seinen rückzug angekündigt er wurde von
vielen experten als ein er moderator
af.de eingeschätzt sein erklärtes ziel
war immer dass man es schafft mit den
anderen parteien koalitionen einzugehen
dass eine zusammenarbeit möglich ist
forderungen wie den austritt
deutschlands aus der europäischen union
die in die afg in ihrem
bundestagswahlprogramm stehen hatte
lehnte er zum beispiel ab bald soll der
bundesvorstand der afg neu gewählt
werden und das wird sich ja ganz
entscheidend für die künftige
ausrichtung der partei die vorsitzenden
geben ja schließlich den ton an meistens
zumindest aber wie genau spricht dieser
ton eigentlich an wir sind heute die
wählerinnen und wähler der afd um das zu
beantworten schauen wir uns jetzt mal
die zahlen und daten der
forschungsgruppe wahlen an und wir
kommen wir zurück zum klischee vom
anfang den ganzen wahltag überführte die
forschungsgruppe wählerbefragungen über
der afd haben sich folgende ergebnisse
gezeigt die afg war tatsächlich
insgesamt erfolgreicher bei männern als
bei frauen was allerdings natürlich
längst nicht heißt dass sie nur von
männern gewählt wird altersmäßig war die
partei am stärksten bei den 30 bis 59
jährigen das bedeutet so alt ist der
typische afd weder gar nicht das zeigt
auch das abschneiden der afd im osten
jeder vierte in dieser mittleren
altersgruppe entschied sich für die afd
aber auch bei den 18 bis 29 jährigen
wurde die afg mit 19 prozent die
stärkste kraft und hier sind wir auch
wieder beim thema ost west die afg wurde
insgesamt zweitstärkste partei im osten
mit 20,5 prozent auf nur 8,2 prozent und
rang fünf kam sie dagegen im westen dass
sie in den sogenannten neuen
bundesländern also tatsächlich
wesentlich besser abschneidet als sie
den alten das stimmt falls ihr noch
einen beweis braucht hier sind mal die
top fünf der höchsten zweitstimmenanteil
der afg in allen wahlkreisen in
deutschland versus die los auf der
wahlkreise mit den niedrigsten hand
teilen also hier seht ihr die top 5 mit
görlitz der sächsischen schweiz
osterzgebirge bautzen 1 erzgebirgskreis
1 und mittelsachsen dagegen die euro 5
mit münster köln 2 hamburg altona
hamburg eimsbüttel und hamburg nord was
ost und west aber gemeinsam haben es
sind die gleichen wähler gruppen in
denen die afd besonders viel
unterstützung bekommt natürlich auf
jeweils unterschiedlichem niveau das
sind eher wählerinnen und wähler
mittleren alters und arbeiter sowie
arbeitslose außerdem erreiche die partei
sowohl in ost als auch in west vor allem
menschen mit einem niedrigeren
bildungsabschluss speziell bei den 35
bis 59 jährigen das heißt natürlich
nicht dass es keine menschen mit höherem
bildungsabschluss gibt die die fdp
wählen logisch die forschungsgruppe
wahlen hat außerdem untersucht bei
welchen dingen die menschen in
deutschland die afg als kompetent
ansehen welche themen sind das
wir sehen da sie regelmäßig das bei
denen kompetenz werten die in den
befragungen dann herauskommen die afg
sehr wenig anteile erhält also das heißt
vor allem beim wirtschaftlichen
kompetenzen
steuerpolitik etc bei diesen wichtigen
themen in denen immer mit 23 prozent die
fdp 11 d die richtigen konzepte in
diesen bereichen hat es gibt eigentlich
nur ein bereich
in dem die afg mit mal so auf knapp
zweistellige kompetenz welt kommt und es
ist der bereich flüchtlinge integration
ausländerpolitik also hier
das ist ein thema das die afg ja sehr
stark besetzt und es ist ein thema das
auch sehr in der gesellschaft
polarisiert in den einstellungen und
hier sehen wir als einzige kompetenz
vielleicht noch ein bisschen auch bei
thema corona und bekämpfung der pandemie
dass die afg so ein bisschen merkbare
hre anteile erhält im vergleich zu den
anderen parteien
flüchtlingspolitik integration und
ausländerpolitik gehören demnach also
tatsächlich zu den wenigen stärker
besetzten themen der afd genauso wie die
korona politik nach diesen befragungen
liegt es für die forschungsgruppe wahlen
nahe dass bei den fdp anhängern der
unmut über bestimmte themen im
vordergrund steht gerade bei der
wahlentscheidung auch bei aktuellen
umfragen zur corona politik für das
politbarometer im november wird deutlich
dass afg anhänger sich durchgängig
konträr zur gesamtheit positionieren sie
finden die geltenden corona maßnahmen
mehrheitlich übertrieben und die meisten
lehnen eine impfpflicht und 3 oder zweig
regelungen ab die mit den crooner
maßnahmen unzufrieden sind also vor
allem in der afg anhängerschaft
vertreten bei einer politbarometer
umfrage 2009 10 gaben nur 31 prozent der
befragten anhänger an dass die afg
hauptsächlich wegen ihrer politischen
forderungen gewählt wird 64 prozent
dagegen also fast zwei drittel die
meinen wegen eines denkzettel für andere
parteien der afc scheint bei der
bundestagswahl 2021 viele unzufriedene
angesprochen zu haben denen sie eine
stimme gegeben hat das soll von mir gar
keine bewertung oder kein bashing seien
an der stelle sicher ist das auch keine
unwichtige funktion und etwas man ernst
nehmen sollte dieses protestpotenzial
dass es gibt aber es ist eben eine
beobachtung und zuletzt wollen wir uns
noch anschauen ob sich die partei jetzt
fest etabliert hat im bundestag und dort
auch unter umständen bleibt oder ob sie
nach einiger zeit wieder verschwindet
2013 wurde die afb gegründet
vergleichsweise ist sie also noch immer
eine junge partei gut jetzt muss ich
direkt dazu sagen das war vielleicht ein
bisschen klick dating natürlich können
wir die zukunft nicht vorhersagen aber
wir können euch erklären wie die
meinungen dazu sind dennoch dazu hat die
forschungsgruppe wahlen in der
vergangenheit schon menschen in
deutschland gefragt und würde ich ganz
repräsentativ
diese grafik hier zeigt euch die antwort
kurve zur frage wird die afd langfristig
erfolgreich sein die grafik beginnt im
juli 2013 und endet im oktober 2008 zehn
bis zur bundestagswahl 2017 trauten
deutlich mehr menschen der afg ist nicht
zu langfristig erfolgreich zu sein nach
der wahl 2017 änderte sich das dann aber
andrea wolf von der forschungsgruppe
wahlen schätze situation so also ich
gehe schon davon aus dass die afg
langfristig im parteiensystem einfach da
sein wird es gibt immer themen die
einfach unterschiedlich diskutiert
werden zudem unterschiedliche meinungen
gibt es gibt immer unzufriedenheit in
der bevölkerung
und wir haben mit der afg da eben eine
plattform jetzt auf der diese
unzufriedenheit eben auch aufgefangen
werden kann was dagegen darüber traut
ihr der afg zu sich langfristig zu
festigen und dann wird sich die partei
wie anhand der regional unterschiedlich
ausfallenden daten die bei euch vorhin
gezeigt haben eher regional stark
verankert eure meinung dazu gerne unten
in die kommentare und bitte muss man ja
immer wieder dazu sagen bleibt sachlich
wir haben jetzt gesehen an den klischees
vom anfang ist also tatsächlich ein
kleines bisschen was dran aber sie sind
natürlich nicht die ganze wahrheit die
afg ist insgesamt erfolgreicher bei
männern als bei frauen mehr im osten als
im westen ist vor allem im mittleren
alters bereich stark und spricht viele
unzufriedene an genau wie in der partei
selbst gibt es aber auch bei der
wählerschaft eben unterschiedliche
positionen gemäßigter radikaler älter
und jünger und vieles mehr so und hier
findet ihr in unserer video zu den
jungen menschen in deutschland sich
vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen hat
und ein spannendes video dazu warum
umfragen bei der ard in der
vergangenheit oft schwierig waren gerne
mal reingucken danke dafür und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]